thanks everybody for uh
coming today and i'd like to thank don
wayne uh for setting this up and mario
and kim who i've never met before uh but
uh i think today was unique for me
because it's the first time ever in my
life
as i told kim i bought his book recently
and this is the first time i've ever had
the author of a book ruin the ending of
his own book
and i appreciate that that's a unique
thing for me so if i can get the uh
presentation up so many of you know that
uh this is the 400th
anniversary of the telescope
and we've created this world the year of
astronomy and as mario spoke to the
other day people have been celebrating
this for at least three years
so uh the 400th anniversary uh of three
different years apparently but what i'm
going to talk about is
is a subtitle for which could be
the legacy of galileo today and seeing
beyond what he was capable of seeing but
using technology that
is credited to him obviously
mario is a much more scholar as to the
origins of the telescope and the
intellectual property associated with
the telescope but in conventional
circles
he was the first one to train it to the
night sky to do astronomical research
with it
and the first telescope i'll talk about
is a galilean telescope it's a
refracting telescope which my colleagues
and i
have built at the south pole
and what's interesting about this
telescope is that
it really could not happen without a
galilean underpinning it could not
happen
and be as sensitive as it is without
being of the galilean design namely a
refractor so i'll be talking about that
and the main goal of what we're trying
to do with this telescope
is to study uh the the
light signature the heat left over from
the big bang and it's a relatively
complex subject and of course we've been
hearing a lot about uh
very complex uh science fiction uh of
course there's a lot of scientific fact
uh in kim's writing as as i uh
undoubtedly appreciate but um i i won't
uh i won't spend too much time on the
motivation or the underpinnings in
uh
of the science of the cosmology that
we're doing with uh the telescope that
we have at the south pole instead i'll
highlight some of the unique features
that are invented that galileo as i say
was the first to train it towards the
night sky of course we're not looking at
the night sky in the visible light as
galileo did instead we're using
microwave vision we're using a radio
telescope in fact and it's interesting
in fact to note that a radio telescope
can be made of a galilean design to some
people that's that's quite unusual how
could it be that
you can see through with radio waves
using the same types of materials that
galileo himself used so i'll explain
somewhat of the design but but the basic
synopsis of what i'm talking about today
is shown here and this is a first of
many space-time diagrams what we see
today is more familiar it's the these
structures here galaxies and stars and
the mature universe that we believe
today to be 13.7 billion years old it's
actually pretty interesting we know this
with an uncertainty of one digit in the
last decimal place so we know it to plus
or minus 100 million years and that
would be like knowing being able to
guess the year
or within six months of somebody who's
70 years old to guess exactly which
month in the history of the world they
were born so knowing that i know it's
certainly more accurately than i know uh
most people's birthdays and birth years
so we know this with fantastic precision
and this comes from studying the
microwave background
by my predecessors and and the hard work
of theorists
as well as experimentalists
such as myself and i'll explain some of
the uh some of our understanding and how
it's developed but today we live here
and we believe the universe began in
what's called a hot big bang
which is to say that all the matter and
radiation in the universe was compacted
together in a small volume of space and
that big bang took place in a sense
everywhere in the universe and created
space as the universe aged so um
to talk about that retro you know might
require
even more eloquent language than i'm
capable of maybe i'll have kim help
help me out to explain it but in essence
what we're looking is we're using the
fact as galileo did
to use the telescope as as both a means
to transport yourself in space to become
closer to an object but also in time so
when i look out into the audience i see
people not as they are exactly at this
moment at this instant i'm seeing them a
few billionths of a second after the
light left their face and came to me so
we're seeing things back farther and
farther in time the more we look back
and back in space and that's the key
notion for the cosmology that we do
today and the theory the belief is if we
look back to where there's nothing in
our way
uh nothing obstructing the view we can
see back to the beginning of light when
light was when light first came into
existence namely the big bang and and
shortly thereafter uh we can see
everything that's happened since then
and that's what we use the microwave
background radiation for it's the famous
three kelvin uh
microwave background
so we we call it a light echo or heat a
relic of the big bang
and we believe that the galaxies and
stars that we see today trace themselves
to a primordial uh soup of material
namely the first stars and
proto-galaxies that i've reformed my
colleague mike norman's in the back and
he's uh he's developed computer codes
and and algorithms that basically he
calls a computer a universe in a box
where he can simulate
billions of particles billion
billions of particles and simulate the
creation of these objects which then
later grow into these objects what i
study is this object here this is the
microwave background the cosmic
microwave background radiation and it's
the heat left over from the big bang and
in a sense this is the limit of our
vision we can't go any farther back in
time using light or radio waves or
x-rays
this is where our vision stops but it's
not where time started
it's actually occurring this heat was
imprinted 380 000 years after the big
bang so there's no way just by using
light that we can look any any farther
back in time than this region here
but we know that this pattern must have
been established
by an earlier epoch which we call
inflation and this happened in an
extremely bizarre uh
stage of the universe's development when
it was a few fractions quanta of time
old and i certainly won't have time to
get into our understanding of what that
that sentence really means but
essentially this i term the spark that
lit the big bang that then
became uh this explosive expansion uh
the relics in both heat and light we
still see today so this is sort of the
rough uh overarching view
and uh of the cosmology that i'm going
to attempt to describe and how we came
to the understanding that we have today
and how we're going to probe deeper uh
by understanding this event this epoch
in the universe's history not by using
light but by using gravity we hope to be
able to understand this epoch that took
place before and led to it
so as i said the cmb itself is this is
this thermal
background as mario was saying a
paleontologist are lucky they have these
dinosaur bones they can recreate maybe
using their own fictional imagination
what kind of environments and make a
diorama but unfortunately in in
cosmology we only have one universe we
don't have millions of bones we don't
have millions of chemicals that we can
mix together we have one universe
and we hope to do statistical tests on
that single universe
and uh and that makes it challenging
because we only really have things that
come to us either asteroid fragments
meteorites etc or light or radioaids
we hope to use gravity as well but to
date that has not been done so the cmb
is this light uh relic this light fossil
that's come from the early universe to
us today it was predicted by physicist
astrophysicists in the 30s george gamov
and others he predicted that if the
universe began began in a hot dense
state
that well we would see an afterglow of
that state later on that would be much
much cooler and it would trace to the
fact that the universe expands as it
cools as cools as it expands
and ages
as it ages it expands
the cmb was detected by
these guys here shown in a much more
modern picture and to my knowledge this
is the only cosmology experiment to ever
take place in new jersey
uh this is uh the famous bell labs
telescope which doesn't really look like
a telescope at all but it's a big horn
and you'll see a lot of these when we
discuss our technology today we don't
use our eyes in
cmb science we use detectors that that
transduce light or radio waves
capture them amplify them and detect
them uh and so we're sensitive in a
different way than galileo was using his
vision or photographs as astronomers did
later and now ccd cameras etc
um but it wasn't really understood uh
whether or not the cmb for this picture
to make sense
these structures grew out of these
structures which look more simple than
these these structures look more
complicated than this structure here and
so the idea is that gravity is acting on
gas and irregularities in density in the
early universe causing matter to come
together and of course galileo studied
uh gravity as well
and um
and those
over densities and under densities in
the universe it was thought would create
not a perfectly smooth
uh cmbn
cmb
distribution but in fact it would be
irregular
and actually uh one of my colleagues art
wolf in the astronomy department here in
the physics department uh predicted that
the there should be an anisotropy the
the universe should not be perfectly
smooth in every direction receiving
exactly three kelvin worth of radiation
he predicted that in different regions
of the sky you'd see different values of
that
temperature in the universe and that
those fluctuations in temperature have
the same origin as the origin of
galaxies stars and clusters of stars and
galaxies
so we believe that pattern of
irregularities today this is a kind of
cartoon vision of what it looks like
it's not a moon of jupiter that we don't
know about instead it's a globe of the
sky but projected as if you're god
looking down on this uh sphere of the
sky okay but seen in microwave vision
where blue represents over densities of
matter where light escaping from there
will be colder and red represents warmer
regions of the sky but again this
irregularity is quite small it's only
one part and 10 to the fifth okay so
that's a part and a hundred thousand
and what that means is to give you an
example that's about how smooth this
ball bearing is the ball bearing surface
relative to its radius is smooth to a
part of one in a hundred thousand
so that's pretty fantastic that we can
actually see
images of the microwave background that
are this uh that are that are that small
and actually we're gonna go much farther
beyond that we already have and i'll
show you some pictures of that uh
towards the end in a few minutes
so the question is where do these
fluctuations come from this is another
space time diagram but this i kind of
call a particle time diagram it's
actually a stuff time diagram because
i'm showing the evolution of stuff
matter protons
photons here helium nuclei hydrogen
nuclei
etc and then they become atoms here and
this is when the cmb is produced so we
cannot see farther back in time
because these electrons that are here
free and unbound
act just like the surface of a mirror
they reflect any light if you like or
they absorb any light that you try if
you're appearing back from one of these
structures here you would not be able to
see beyond here because you're
essentially looking at a surface of a
mirror it's only when these electrons
combine with protons to make hydrogen
that we become
a transparent to be able to see from now
today to the surface but you can never
use light to see any farther back than
this time here which is 380 000 years i
said after the big bang and we're down
here 13.7 billion years
okay and another way to visualize this
is if today you know today uh is is the
beginning of may but usually in may in
san diego if you're not from here mario
uh and and kim lives in more northern
california we have may gray
okay and may gray is an overcast layer
and if you're on the ground you can't
use light to see anything beyond the
surface of the overcast as you see it
above you you can't see if there's a
plane flying up there or perhaps there's
an explosion of some kind up there with
light you can't see that but you could
hope to see an explosion the impact of
that explosion maybe on the cloud layer
by using the sound or maybe hearing the
the explosion you could trace that back
to uh to better understand what was the
source of that explosion what was the
source of those perturbations
and that's exactly what we're trying to
do with the microwave background
radiation and as shown here here we are
in the present we're looking back here's
the surface of last scattering we can't
use our eyes to see any farther back in
time but perhaps we can use the
properties of gal of gravity
that later grew out and perturbed the
surface to make it
as irregular
as a ball bearing as i showed before so
this is sort of the brief overview of
the theory i won't talk too much more
about it i'll happy when we have our
question to answer it but this is the
way to bring down the spotlight a little
bit just so
people can see so this is bicep there's
our tattooed
model over here uh no that's not me
and this is a
as i said this is a galilean refracting
telescope but not for light for
microwaves so microwave radiation would
come in from here if this were a
microwave and then this is a a lens cap
really it's really to keep this this
this system cold
and we're trying to keep this cold
because we're looking for a small
fluctuation in the background radiation
which itself is near absolute zero it's
only three degrees above absolute zero
so this is a picture of the telescope
and its mount
and it's a 30 centimeter diameter
telescope 18 inches or so
size lens
and thanks you can bring back up the
light if you like
so this is a schematic diagram of how
the telescope looks and i told you you'd
see more funnels these are our funnels
and i i call this
not even good enough to be a one milli
megapixel camera in other words a
megapixel is a million pixels we have 50
pixels and the reason is our ccd cameras
in your in your phone uh in your in your
in your camera those uh can have
millions of pixels because the
wavelength that you're looking at is
visible optical light and those are
approximately half a micron in diameter
and half of a
half of a millionth of a meter
wavelength what we're looking for in
contour distinction is two millimeter
wavelength and longer one to two to
three millimeter wavelengths and longer
so the so the size of the pixel in your
ccd camera correlates to the size of the
light
lights wavelength that you're looking at
we're looking at microwaves so these are
really physically sized objects
as i said we're trying to see a heat
signature a very tiny fluctuation on top
of something which is almost an absolute
zero to begin with
so the only way to do that is for us to
cool our detectors below the temperature
of the signal itself so we're looking
for something approximately three
degrees kelvin plus or minus
very minuscule fluctuations parts in a
hundred thousand or parts in a million
or even parts in a billion of that so we
cool our detectors down to
0.25 kelvin 250 milli degrees kelvin
and those detectors are ultra sensitive
uh semiconductor detectors which i'll
show you a quick picture i won't go into
too much of the details of it because i
do want to talk mostly about why we put
it where we where we put this telescope
at the south pole that's what most
people want to know
so here's a cutaway light comes in as i
showed it gets refracted and bent to
different spatial places on on the uh on
the array we only have 50 of them here
and these are these little funnels which
actually do just that they funnel light
concentrate it so that we can amplify
this minuscule signal traveling over the
entire course of the universe's history
so if you're a photon this is the last
thing you ever see
after your 13.7 billion year long life
you crash into one of these depending on
where you are on the sky okay and when
we're looking at you
okay so this is what bicep looks like
now where should we put this telescope
well one thought and people always ask
is why not put it you know closer to
home in san diego i mean the south pole
is nice but we have pretty awesome
weather here despite this the may gray
and so here's a picture of palomar which
is uh in san diego county and palomar
sort of came out of use for many
different reasons it's a very large
diameter telescope it's a newtonian
reflecting telescope but one of the
reasons that san diego's light was
becoming encroach was encroaching on the
ability of scientists astronomers to
take
to take sensitive images from here using
photographic plates so this is polluted
by light now they're looking for light
so light to them extra light is a
pollution source for us
heat is a pollution we're looking for
heat we can do our observations during
the day we could do it in a city as long
as there's not radio or microwave or
excess thermal heat
so one reason we go somewhere cold is to
get away from the background of of heat
that's unavoidable on earth on earth
we're roughly 300 degrees above absolute
zero pretty much all uh in most
locations in the on the earth's surface
and we're looking for something 100
times colder and small fluctuations on
top of that
so
we find for us the analog of being
dark for an optical telescope is to have
a very dry atmosphere
water absorbs microwaves we're trying to
absorb these precious microwaves that
came from the big bang they've been
traveling forever for the literally the
entire duration of the universe and we
don't want to miss any of them i'm
showing here a little chemical
description of what's actually happening
inside your microwave oven your
microwave oven operates on wavelengths
about 10 times longer than ones i'm
using but nevertheless the principle is
the same water absorbs microwaves it
causes them to rotate
the microwave radiation causes the
molecules to rotate which is what warms
them up by friction essentially and
that's how you can eat or drink a cup of
coffee which would be hot but the cup
handle doesn't burn you if it's made of
ceramic because the ceramic is dry so we
want to go somewhere extremely dry and
we picked south pole in antarctica so
i'm going to show you a little a little
travelogue here and
and then i'll i'll show you how we
installed it and i'll show you some of
our data which we recently released and
it's really quite exciting to be a part
of the team that has done this because
we've made essentially the deepest
images
of the early universe that have ever
been made
so we chose to go to antarctica and
here's a picture of antarctica these are
the most famous residents of antarctica
and they're walking to work and then we
can see that actually
it seems to be quite inhospitable but we
found
an awful lot of great support here and
this is a little travelogue movie of of
what you do you go down to new zealand
and you pick up your clothes you pick up
your boarding pass there's actually
boarding passes to get on this plane
here this is a c-17 us air force c-17
from washington state
we fly down from our high altitude we
can start to see icebergs after about
three hours
we land this is a super shuttle uh for
antarctica we take this into town this
is a freeway in antarctica
this goes to mcmurdo station which looks
like this this looks like a college
campus
and a mining town
there's a wells fargo atm down there
good for us california
there's a two bars down there this is a
non-smoking bar you can go into it's
very clean this is the smoking bar
it's much darker
and
your vision gets very blurry when you're
there this is this is a snapshot of the
activities going on there okay so you
sleep off the last night's activities
and you get on this aircraft here it's
the c-130 with skis
and you fly to the south pole takes
about three hours
these are some telescopes there i want
you to remember this image this is our
passenger terminal at the south pole
okay
now we got there in a couple of hours
this is scott's party he got there uh
over the course of three months and died
on the way back
we get to stay here
in a place that has a kitchen and a
greenhouse and this is this this is just
the sous chef at the south pole today
it's a fantastic place to be able to go
to to do science i'll show you
uh let me go back a little bit in the
movie i just think it's so funny that
this person is here as a susha
so and it says here i read about her
she's been a personal chef to heather
graham and liv tyler and she's not even
our main chef she's just the sushi so
kim had it harder when he was there he
stayed in the actual south pole dome
which you can't see is over here the
famous dome this this
new station cost about a quarter of a
billion dollars but it's actually doing
fantastic research and um it's a
wonderful facility it's not just for the
us it's for all 14 countries or so that
uh do astronomy or do science from
antarctica of all kinds
so i'll resume that so you go there you
take your picture in front of here
that's that's your hero shot you know it
took you three hours to get there and
take took the other guys months and they
die coming back and you can do it almost
like a ski trip
and then this is a shot of us going to
work we walk across the runway looking
both ways for incoming c-130s and this
is called the dark sector of antarctica
because there's no radio
no radios allowed out there that aren't
essential because all these telescopes
are radio telescopes our telescope is
here
and now it's over there
and these are other different types of
our colleagues and their radio telescope
now look at this thing here
that looks kind of familiar i would say
that is a shot of the
whoops
let me go back to this
yeah so this if you remember looks just
like the south pole passenger terminal
but it's actually our outhouse
there's no bathrooms up here and
nowadays all the buildings are built up
on stilts because of blowing snow that
comes in a lot of people wonder why do
we put the sensitive telescope up on a
shaky foundation but it's actually quite
a strong foundation and it prevents wind
from doing too much disturbances to our
telescopes our telescope's in here that
that
large instrument that i showed you uh
the galilean refractor is inside of here
and we do observations we can look all
over the sky and it's interesting to
note that this telescope here
is called the south pole telescope this
is a 20 million dollar telescope uh
university of chicago berkeley
and others but this telescope this
gigantic newtonian reflecting telescope
has the exact same sensitivity to what
we're looking for as we do because the
signature of what we're looking for is
actually very very coarse angular
resolution and i'll show you some images
of that uh upcoming
so that's the uh travelogue for for the
uh to get to the telescope these are our
detectors uh we we have two different
microfabricated uh detectors per pixel
so we actually have a hundred detectors
and 50 spatial pixels
these are cool to a quarter of a degree
above absolute zero there are little
resistors whose electrical resistance
for the experts changes as a function of
their thermal
as a function of their temperature so
they're called thermistors and they're
extremely sensitive they're the most
sensitive detectors for this type of
work that you can
can build physically
here's the telescope again so that is
now inside of that larger scoop and the
scoop outside this scoop is not the
telescope itself it's to prevent heat
from coming in from here and getting and
seeing the the front of our telescope
and getting in so it's a type of baffle
really
so there's a telescope this is us
installing it uh this is the cooled part
which uh the innards of which are cooled
down to a quarter of a degree above
absolute zero and these are some scenes
around the south pole after we installed
it inside of here
so these are the images that i wanted to
show you i'll kind of flip back and
forth
no one has ever seen the universe in its
primitive state and it's baby pictures
any clearer than this
these are images that we took over two
years of uninterrupted observations and
those observations allowed us to make
these ultra deep images at two different
wavelengths and the and the two
different wavelengths are important
because uh they have different angular
resolutions
but if you uh observe them together you
can see if you're being contaminated by
any other sources of uh contamination so
the two different maps agree perfectly
and that's extremely exciting so this is
a baby picture of the universe and these
dark spots will later grow into super
clusters of galaxies or they actually
already have uh if if uh
if they remained undisturbed
so this is an extremely high fidelity
thanks to the
clean design of the galilean refractor
the galilean refractor is just like a
spotting scope there's nothing between
your eye and what you're looking at in
our case the early universe there's no
other mirrors like with a newtonian
telescope or a cassegrain telescope
that can be used to distort or corrupt
the image that we're looking at that
being said
here's a nice picture taken by
one of the scientists that we paid a
winter over
at the south pole
we we
the scientists leave after a couple of
weeks or a couple of months
and go back to wherever their home
institution is and we have there are
about 40 people that live uh at that big
station over the summer and what's nice
about that is that uh they they they get
paid pretty healthy salaries they get
about seventy thousand dollars uh and we
tell them you only have to work for one
night because uh there's only one
sunrise in sunset per year in antarctica
and they keep falling for it this is
actually the moon and when the moon is
out
they actually call that sunrise because
in the winter down there there's
absolutely no other sources of light
this is probably taken in july
when the temperatures go down to about
100 degrees fahrenheit
below zero
so this is a summary of our experiment
now this is a trip that we took to
the only working telescope in california
that does this type of science this is
called the polar bear telescope and this
is me and a friend flying up the owens
valley
to visit the telescope which is
located near bishop california that's a
collaboration between ucsd and uc
berkeley colorado university
and a few other institutions scattered
all over the world and this telescope is
built in uh in the owens valley uh not
as its final uh observing location but
instead it's built there so that we can
attest it before we take it down to a
higher and better site in chile this is
the actual owens valley itself we're
flying up it we're going to land around
here and then we're going to drive up
to the telescope this is owens lake it's
actually quite beautiful you're all
invited
to come visit we land at bishop airport
and then we start making the drive up
the mountain this is only located at 7
200 feet above uh sea level it's not
that high it's not it's lower than the
south pole but it's equidistant from
berkeley and ucsd and so it makes it
very convenient for us to test the
telescope before we ship it
so it's very beautiful this is the ineo
national forest
it's quite a luxurious beautiful place
to work
after you've been to the south pole and
you have a room that you can touch both
sides of the walls with your arms
outstretched
then we drive to the telescope facility
itself it's also the home of the owens
valley radio observatory's karma
telescope array that's this structure
here those are an interferometer
and this is the polar bear telescope
after we finish construction of it and
some of my students on it and we're
calibrating it so this is a reflecting
telescope but the reason i wanted to
show this to you is because this we use
to observe the planet jupiter so jupiter
is used in microwave
astronomy as a source of calibration we
know it's temperature exactly we've had
space probes there
perhaps galileo himself was actually
there if kim is right so we know the
physical conditions absolutely and we
know what they'll produce in terms of a
signal if we look at it and that's the
definition of how you calibrate your
telescope you have a known signal that
you're sending in and then you measure a
signal coming out
so this is kind of our postcard picture
we have a blog
mountainpolarbear.blogspot.com
and we have a youtube video of it moving
around it's quite impressive it weighs
about 75 000 pounds and it can slow and
view the whole sky in just a few seconds
and track it very accurately but again
it's not a newtonian telescope
so what i do want to show you here's
famous
galileo
and he's staring up at jupiter and one
of the galilean moons and i want to show
you an image of jupiter unlike anything
you've ever seen before certainly unlike
galileo ever had the opportunity to see
okay so this is jupiter seen through
microwave eyes
pretty spectacular
so with our microwave detectors we only
see one bit of information at a given
time so we build up images this is
jupiter passing through a couple of
weeks ago for the first time ever seeing
jupiter with our telescope called first
light
it's very exciting time for astronomers
and then we can synthesize many of them
together to make an image like this
which has some distortions it's not
because of the moons or
we're not accidentally looking at saturn
instead we have we have looked at saturn
but this is not it
this is due to how we process the data
and their artifacts so we're learning
how these detectors work brand new
detectors brand new telescope and
eventually we'll be in chile
but for now we're in california so it's
quite nice to have this telescope
working here
and i'll leave with this final image of
us at daybreak
commemorating our first light
observations so thank you very much
[Applause]
great thanks
um so um
so actually kind of uh going off of of
brian's presentation
um
i i wanted to just draw one aspect out
of
the galileo's dream book
and the um the use of
what's one of the things that science
fiction allowed uh stan to bring to that
story
was actually a very
one a very clear
description of
the issues at stake in contemporary
physics
and in particular
physics that start to completely change
the way we
uh
you know uh
daily think about the
about time
and of course it's a time travel book so
that's a
part of a part of this part of the story
but these kind of
physical these contemporary uh physical
physics theories about
uh time and its complexity
uh are are likely as destabilizing to
our
view our current world view
as galileo's
ideas
about
advocating for the copernican
system were to his time
and um
and so i i
wanted to
um
ask brian about that aspect of the book
and the ability of fiction and science
fiction in particular to engage these
kinds of contemporary physical theories
here just take this
[Applause]
so um
how do how does science fiction or
concepts in science fiction
advance our notions or or
blend with our notions of time
i found i'm only on chapter three uh in
the book um
and uh i've had it for three days now
but uh but actually it's quite um quite
interesting to me that the blend of
of uh the historical science fact and
the the intuition that galileo had not
necessarily in terms of time travel i
don't think that's going to be a theme i
haven't as i said i haven't finished it
but the the theme that spoke loudest to
me was of the invention and the
collaboration but also a little bit of
the of the of the childlike aspect of
science which i think it was bore who
said that
you know an experimentalist who galileo
was is kind of like a child um
he'll complete he or she will complete
keep doing the same experiment over and
over again unlike a normal person an
adult say because an adult will do it
once get some result like it dislike it
but move on but a child will keep doing
the same result because it gets it gives
them a little spark of the taste of the
pleasure they felt when they did it the
first time and i kind of feel like that
was uh that that resonated with me that
galileo would keep he he almost didn't
believe his invention he almost it was
not capable of uh uh it was so thrilling
to him and it reminded me a little bit
of the descriptions of einstein when he
was meditating on time
and um you know of course galilean we
speak of
galileo and einstein together in what's
called relativity there's a galilean
relativity where time is absolute and
then there's an einsteinian relativity
where time is fluid time is relative to
the observer's state of motion or fixed
nature so i would say you know galileo
is is that paradigm of the classical you
know renaissance that time was absolute
space was absolute and um
and and how we've uh modified and
advanced in the neoclassical or modern
period is that we have fluid notions of
space and time
that have been developed
stan do you want to say something about
the concepts of time in the book
sure the
string and brian
you can tell me if i'm getting this
right but string theory which is this uh
the edge of current uh speculative
physics and cosmology
with the notion that
the universe might be constructed of
smallest possible objects
these strings that are vibrating and
that
their
size is essentially the minimum size
which is something crossing the speed of
light crossing the poly exclusion
principle in that
essentially two very small particles
can't occupy the same space
and so they will be a certain a minimum
distance apart 10 to the negative 34th
of a meter that's really small so it
only takes
10 to the negative 43rd of a second for
light to cross that interval and these
are minima
you can't get lower than that or you
break the standard model of physics as
we understand it
but these things are so small that we
cannot experimentally find them or not
they're they're theoretical objects only
and
like the cyclotron that they have under
geneva
uh it gets things up to a certain energy
before they they collide together these
small particles if you were to just take
proportionally a cyclotron that would be
big enough to reveal these string size
objects it would be as big around as the
galaxy
so we can't build that cyclotron and we
can't as far as we know investigate
strings but we have done an experiment
to show
some entanglement which is something
happening
a spooky action at a distance as
einstein called it and they have
experimentally confirmed that you can
charge the spin factor of a mic of a
subatomic particle in one place and due
to the laws of complementarity and
believe me i'm speaking as an english
major here and they are just metaphors
as far as i'm concerned
nevertheless there is a law of
complementarity that if you give a spin
to one
particle there is an opposite particle
that immediately takes the opposite spin
no matter how far it away it is so the
information for the first one has been
conveyed to the second one
simultaneously across space and so
they've done it on two of the opposite
sides of france
and
faster than light
this has been proven by experiment and
therefore entanglement seems to be real
this is my complete justification for my
31st century physics
string theorists will say well for all
this to work out mathematically in the
most beautiful way possible which i
don't know what that means
there would have to be ten dimensions
and i don't know what that means either
but then they're also saying that we're
only seeing five to ten percent of the
mass of the universe as lit material and
there's dark matter
there's also suddenly the realization
that the universe is apparently
expanding at speed rather than being
pulled in by its own gravity dark energy
dark energy dark matter
i'm getting the impression that we are
completely at sea in terms of the true
nature of the universe and that we live
in uh
three dimensions of space one of time
that we understood this space time
continuum a little bit in einsteinian
sense
we're still basically newtonian but we
could at least comprehend the notion of
einsteinian's einsteinian space but this
10-dimensional space what's the sixth
what's the seventh what's the eighth
well from
for my purposes writing a novel i could
just simply say that by the 31st century
they've managed to work out some math
and some and some experiments to confirm
like this entanglement experience
experiment which we've already
accomplished to confirm some of these
things and say that dark matter is
really just another name for a another
one of the 10 dimensions dark energy a
name for another 10 dimension
a certain point i could just go hog wild
nobody knows nobody knows at this point
but it's interesting that actually uh
one of the fathers of
modern string theory edwin
at the institute for aesthetic he said
things to the nature of that
the influence of physics much like
newton and galileo was that they
influenced and created new mathematics
and now what they're saying is that
string theory is mathematics not on the
31st century but the 22nd century i
happen to think it's of the 31st century
i think you're right
it's very difficult for an
experimentalist to see a theory that
can't be tested so uh but you are right
it is that it's been spoken that it is
advanced math that we don't know we only
know the contours of the mathematics at
this point we don't know the details
i have galileo saying well this is just
the end of physics when the situation is
described to him at the end of
experimental physics but
and it may be true in fact there are
books out there the end of physics the
end of science that we reach
limits to what we can even try to
understand
and you know i was just checking the
time and i
wanted to include the audience if there
were
questions from the audience for the
panel
do we
have anybody yet
in front
just to break the ice what is the um
refractor lens made of
uh it's actually made of teflon
and polyethylene high density
polyethylene the same thing that milk
bottles used to be made of and then we
coat it with a type of teflon
i have a question to follow up with that
one um it looked like on the the sensor
the tubes that are collecting the the
particles um there were a bunch of
different size tubes different diameters
yes uh why yeah so those are for the uh
to collect different types of different
wavelengths of light so i said the size
of your ccd camera is dictated by the
wavelength of light so we want to see
two different wavelengths of light
except the radio waves at these
frequencies so those are in the funnels
themselves those those are called
corrugated microwave feed horns they
basically collect light of different
frequencies i actually wanted to
to congratulate kim on his description
of the refractor as galileo
described the different properties of
the lenses and that's uh if you read the
the those those beginning chapters
you'll see a blend of his intuition and
his experimentation which i thought was
very well done
although he may as mario has pointed out
have lied about all of that after the
fact
i i wish that i had known what mario has
discovered in this last year in the
record
that galileo may have actually seen a
model of the telescope so they didn't
back engineer it by brilliance alone but
perhaps just looked at one and went home
and reproduced it which is kind of funny
and would have made a great scene
in general the the the truth of the
situation is more interesting than a
simpler story that you make up true
science fiction yes
i have two questions um first of all the
the
polar bear telescope is going to chile
what's the reason for chile receiving
that and then secondly
the information that you gather from the
telescopes is it shared equally between
those 14 countries
so um the reason we're going to chile
is because we want to be above the
atmospheric water contamination same
reason we go to the south pole but
having been to the south pole and trying
to do science there it's very
challenging uh to get materials in and
out of there and as i said if you're not
on the flight that leaves february 15th
you're there until november and i've got
teaching and a wife and
all those things so you don't want to be
there but that it's nice in one sense it
makes you discipline the other sense
that's bad is that you can't really
there's no room for error
chile we can get fedex basically
overnight our one you know two day
delivery so we're going to go there it's
just as high quality a site in some ways
it might be superior there's a religious
war going on between chile versus south
pole uh i won't get into it but
after
when i'm back to speak about that maybe
we can talk about that but but the as
far as the data shared between the 14
countries those 14 countries are the
countries that uh sign the antarctica
treaty which prevents them from
exploring for gold and drilling for oil
and things like that on the continent
and testing nuclear weapons so their
signatories to the treaty but we don't
they can stay in the south pole uh
station which is built entirely by the
u.s but
each experiment is autonomous
within that so they do experiments there
on the atmosphere and other types of
experiments we don't participate in
those and other countries do their own
experiments there
i had a philosophical question
kim talked about you know projecting
into the future in order to sort of
avoid the problem of we haven't quite
figured it out yet and brian says yes it
might be the end of science
but mario as a science historian
would you see
what they're talking about and not soon
not not in a hundred years but some day
will you or your colleagues of the
future
sort of have written the history of
science much as someone has probably
written the definitive history of buggy
whips
you know that in fact will we
in a a thousand years in fact at the
current rate of discovery
perhaps
find
you know everyone projects everyone says
oh we've you can't discover any more
things there aren't any more things to
discover
but in some sense at the levels of of
particles that kim was talking about
you're physically prevented from
discovering more things
and do you do you any of you see that
you know science or art or other things
may cease
to progress you know and this would be
i think a tragedy but
you know what we find to do if we can't
do science for example
one thing that
i've noticed you know about the you know
beliefs in the in the end of science
actually i mean the ones that i've seen
tend to come from scientists themselves
and they tend to be associated with so
in the early morning period you know
bacon and the cart
you know basically the idea is that you
know once you got
the right method
right i mean if it's the right method
then it's just a matter of applying the
right method and you know
so if you read
you know
descartes you know he thinks that
if he got the right amount of money
he could have figured out everything in
a matter of years
and you have the same kind of kind of
insane optimism in bacon the business
you know look you know we got the method
now it's just a matter of funding give
us the funding and it's going to be done
very quickly so the the beliefs in the
end of science actually tend to be
associated with over-confident
statements about
methods
and they're in their in their beliefs by
the scientists not by
you know the critics
about the possibility of
you know future history of science
probably you know
i believe that you know maybe in a few
years we will not be able to do anything
because you know everything will be
covered by trade secrets or intellectual
property that we would not be able to
have access to the sources
maybe when we
stop running out of new plot lines for
science fiction novels
we'll have you know completed the end of
science and the end of art because david
has another question
well uh i i don't think we're going to
run out of science fiction ideas very
soon
but
then again i have my own biases in that
direction but it is telling that um stan
and i and a number of other people have
moved away from
um some of the classic furniture of
science fiction and that is
warp drive star trek type things i still
do that now and then stan for swore that
he's more honest than i long ago
um
but when we feel we're actually playing
with the net up
we tend to move away from some of those
child put away the childish things but i
wanted to ask
this is a this is a work in which i
think it's very important
to make
a distinction between three kinds of
things that you're doing stan and i want
your comment on this and one is
where the reader can say i am reading
this book and
here in this passage
i am getting an artful
fictionalized representation of things
that i can then take home as
probably what happened
according to the best information
area two is i get a feeling now
that this is when stan is
extrapolating and i as a reader and fine
with that
and now i'm getting to a point where
this is stan
and me
having fun together
and we're going off where it's clearly
not true
but it is
it has a more artistic truth
and
i have read many novels in which this
attempt
this attempt to be fair by
somehow signaling that you're in this
area now you're in this area now you're
in this area now
is a total failure i'm thinking of ada
by nabakov where he doesn't bother
trying to let you know
which of these territories you're in or
where the world split and i'm wondering
if
if you were thinking along these lines
at all
these three different modes yes i
definitely was david there i wanted to
present
galileo's own history in a way that
didn't distort it into something else
because the story is itself is
interesting important it has its own
integrity there was no reason to mess
with it being such a great story but i
thought it would be interesting to
suggest really powerfully
that what happened to galileo was
achieved by him as against some worse
fates that could have happened when i
read that giordano bruno was burned at
the stake when galileo was 36 years old
and a working professor in padua i had
not in my ignorance put together the
timing there to realize that this was
something happening in his lifetime and
could have happened to him
so that
he escaped a worse fate in the trial and
he needed to work towards escaping
getting burned at the stake
so this is the great act of science
fiction you can then you can then
physicalize the alternative so that in
one of the chapters one of the
alternative
presents that galileo was negotiating he
does get burned at the stake it's kind
of an awful scene
um
and then the other thing i was reading
the renaissance literature itself to get
the the sense of the times and they're
always fooling around with these
elements there's a lot of fantasy in
renaissance literature there's a great
book called
hypnotica matcha the strife of love in a
dream
an italian it's a somewhat soft porn but
it's also just a kind of gigantic
science fiction romance which is a new
well we think of it as a new kind of
horrible compound genre that it's doing
very well right now but in fact there is
and um in the um
say 1590 the same thing beautifully
illustrated and privately published so i
felt the playfulness uh possible i had
been such a realist a rather
conservative science fiction writer no
faster than light travel no aliens that
could talk and no time travel for sure
because all those things are impossible
and at that point you're off into the
realm of fantasy rather than science
fiction and then at a certain point when
i had this notion of galileo flying
through his telescope off to jupiter i
thought
well why not i mean why why be
conservative why be realistic i'm
already a science fiction writer i'm
tagged with wild
craziness already by my genre definition
and yet here i am playing
hard science fiction writers talk about
playing with the net up like otherwise
it's tennis with the net down you can
just do any damn thing you please and
that's most of science fiction and
fantasy but hard science fiction plays
with the net up although as i always
point out there's also a handy dandy
device that shrinks the tennis ball that
goes right through the net at any point
when you want it to
so i thought well i want to play that
game too the novel seemed to demand it
and it was a great pleasure and there
have been people commenting about hand
waving the reviews of the book says
there's some vigorous hand waving by
robinson when it comes to time travel
well of course i mean how else are you
going to explain it but there's hand
waving and there's hand waving if you
think about those indonesian hand
dancers then maybe hand waving isn't
quite so bad there can be some style
involved in the sentences created
there's a couple more questions and uh
don
well
the hand waving is certainly elegant
and
and so was brian's presentation of his
research
the elegance is really itself uh very
interesting to me
um
because there's a formal aspect to
both stan's novel in the way in which
time is is treated in the novel
and to the way in which brian presented
what you know your research and i i
can't pretend to understand really what
you're doing as a physicist but the
formal aspect of it is very interesting
to me
uh in stan's novel uh
i i sense that
you know mario said it's well it's it's
not it's a historical novel but it's
also a science fiction novel
and the the two get collapsed and those
two categories of genres really get
collapsed in a fascinating way and
there's a sense in which looking to the
future speculative culture becomes a way
of understanding
not only understanding the past but
understanding the process
very differently from the way we've
understood history in the past
and i had the sense that something
similar is going on with brian's
research because of the technology that
you have accessible to you
about
the past you know the history of the
universe basically it's just an
observation and i'm not sure that it
correlates
um i i was interested in um the play
between the visual images that we saw
earlier and your science fiction and if
this was the first time you've done a
presentation like that or are you
thinking of integrating images into your
books
um
you know no one has commented on the
images and so i was wondering
you know how how that's sort of
essential to all of your presentations
in a different way well for me this is
the collaboration with sheldon uh
sheldon and todd and his crew
put together the visuals i myself have
had a
lifetime prejudice against visual images
in my talks and readings and i think of
my books as books the fact that
eventually on your ipad i could begin to
do the soundtrack and
it gets a little overwhelming um because
i still want to think of it principally
as a string of sentences and i still am
very conservative person aesthetically
yeah not politically
but um what we've done this before uh a
couple years ago where uh sheldon and
his team do the visuals and i can't even
see them so then you're just counting on
synchronicity
uh and it it's
i don't know
i saw a little uh
web movie of it afterwards but the truth
is i don't know whether
how the synchronicities work or not
because i'm not seeing
the visual images behind me and so i
this is for me since i would never
collaborate in writing because why would
you when it's the only place where you
can do what you want
it's neat to be able to do a
collaboration that is multimedia where
also there's an element of it that it's
crucial but not your responsibility i've
never had that before either it's kind
of fun
it's it's uh it's fun and as stan says
we depend upon
you know luck and synchronicity and um
because it's it's the planning behind it
is is is amazingly sparse
and uh you know we kind of cast around a
very general idea we start to
gather a cast of characters who bring
other things to the table
and uh and then the visuals take
actually quite a bit of
effort to make it takes a long time to
make these things because the technology
is still
very new and um so there aren't really
standard methods
um
uh
so you know but i uh you know thinking
about the images that would go with with
this uh uh these presentations today was
to try and think about how
you know the the you know this this
effect of of galileo extending the human
eye in this radical way that that
significantly displaced our role and our
position in the universe
had upon that time and the and the
and then even the the the artifacts and
structures around those images you know
the the the hand that draws them the the
way he tries to use the uh as mario
describes the the
moons rotating around jupiter or the sun
spots in like cinematic flip books
um
so here we've been
seeing these images that are are
taken by very um you know these aren't
taken by a single eye looking at these
planets these are taken by scanners
looking at them in all these various
ways as brian is showing us and then we
synthesize images out of them so in the
presentation today trying to show the
kind of artifacts of that synthesis to
to show that these are a kind of there's
a construction to these photographs
and um and then the whole thing is
actually choreographed via text
messaging to the projector booth up
there with mike when i when i hear kim
saying something is like okay play this
clip now and
so um so it's a very you know 21st
century methodology
uh left for maybe the last question i
don't think nasa even has done
simulations like they have with these
images of the moon doing their spinnings
or jupiters or the polar i i believe
these are just simply new in the world
yeah so we can see then what we get from
nasa and then the kinds of next
transform that next kind of
transformations we can do with them
yeah well i actually thought that you
were controlling everything from your
laptop because it looked perfectly
synchronized so okay okay i think you
guys only way to discover honey medium
actually uh so my question is uh about
um
this so galileo kind of belongs to the
age when he and a few other people
around that time
uh really discovered and established
a scientific experimental method
which was 500 years ago
now two years ago there was a feature
article wired which i'm sure that some
of you know
by a wired editor chris anderson which
was called 500 years later when the
theory
deluge
deluge makes scientific method obsolete
and as i'm sure you know i mean the
article was a kind of caricature but in
the same time because it's really
amplified something but i think what
amplified is very real
is the explosion of data
right available to dozens of scientific
fields
and the argument which was made is that
well because we have so much data we
don't need to make experiments right we
don't need to make theory we don't need
to make models we can just look for
correlations
and
again i'm making maybe caricature
article but that was a general drift
so uh now the work you're describing
right looking at the early stage
university it actually looked like a
very classical science as you create a
particular equipment you can collect
particular data you have a kind of whole
model the time space kind of model
but there are probably other areas of
astronomy where in fact we do have
perhaps something that chris anderson
was fantasizing about or maybe not
so maybe you know from anybody some
reflections about
galileo the beginning experimental
method
versus this new kind of data age which
we entered about maybe 10 years ago
all right
so um let's say and then i i'm not
familiar with that article but uh one
thing i
could not emphasize in my talk is that
um we are doing classical astronomy in
many ways we're looking making images it
just happens to be at the radio
frequencies but what i attempted um what
i neglected to say uh was that
what we're actually trying to image is
not to make images of light but to make
images of gravity and we're kind of on
the threshold of what will be in my mind
the next great frontier that perhaps
even galileo couldn't have envisioned
which is something called gravitational
astronomy where you're not using light
radio waves x-rays get nothing in the
grav and the electromagnetic spectrum
whatsoever
using the properties of pure gravity to
detect uh astrophysical astronomical
processes including my research which
would be these remnants from this
extremely early time that imprint
themselves only by gravity because we
can't see beyond this point in the
universe's age so i would say that this
uh this will be a revolution not unlike
galileo's revolution of looking at the
you're you're opening up it's it's like
if humans discovered they had a new
sense which they never knew about before
and how that would change art and
culture well we're going to change that
in astronomy and it's a matter of
technological progress but we're getting
there this is ligo
lisa very large projects that are
ongoing now but i do expect that they'll
bear fruit in the upcoming decades and
then
we have a new revolution in front of us
and we'll play a role in that as well in
cosmology
[Music]
a few comments about the the the shift
that uh you mentioned i mean there is no
doubt that i mean at this point there is
uh so much work that is uh you know so
data intensive that you know you can't
find uh any you know real president but
uh in terms of data processing i mean
think about say astronomical tables say
you know say the rudolph table circa
1630.
you're talking already
massive amount of data already kind of
data processing techniques
uh techniques to figure out to kind of
figure out error
both observational error and you know uh
add-on calculation so there is already a
lot of
uh data intensive work in astronomy not
in uh say mechanics
but in astronomy if you think you know
just think about
you know simple things like say
uh
you know calculate the procession of the
equinoxes right so basically you have to
look at how the north pole the north
celestial pole you know seems to move
you need
you know you need to tabulate
observations over hundreds of years
so and the babylonians were already
doing this so so what i'm saying there
is a huge amount of
so and those and there isn't really a
lot of work on those aspects of science
because they're totally boring
i know but you know but by no i'm not
saying the results i'm saying though
for historians to
you know do the kind of work is like you
really need to have it's an acquired
taste
uh
and it doesn't you know and not a lot of
people you know you know take take to
them so but anyway so
there is there is quite a bit of stuff
um so i think we're already about 15
minutes past our time and there's
another event coming in here so i i'm
gonna have to clear the room so
thank you all thank you
[Applause]